hello again Guardians sir will be making
his usual return to the tower tomorrow
at one a.m. pacific standard time except
this time he's going to have some new
goodies first and foremost they'll have
a typical lot of four items one armor
piece for each class as well as a random
weapon what's going to be interesting to
see is if he's going to have any of the
new exotics that the dark below dlc has
brought with it in addition as of last
week he has started to sell a new
currency called exotic shards which you
can purchase for seven strange coins you
can also get exotic shards from
dismantling and exotic here's a fun pro
tip though you can take an existing
exotic weapon that you've maxed out in
terms of experience and break it down
for at least two shards this is very
reminiscent to when people were breaking
down max experience legendary weapons
for five to six energies instead of the
typical two to three so take advantage
of this if you have any duplicate
weapons that you happen to have leveled
up back to zero though you'll now have
12 new versions of previous exotics that
will change week to week based on the
preview we can see that he offers two
pieces of armor for each class in
addition it also appears you will have
six weapons for you to upgrade as well
each upgrade will require you to have
the old version of the exotic and an
exotic shard to purchase it once you
purchase it however you'll lose all the
experience you've gained for the item
and we'll have to re level it therefore
again if you happen to have duplicates
and may be wise to use the non leveled
version and upgrade that so you don't
have to lose out on using one of your
stronger weapons or armors another pro
tip here would be to save turning in all
your thursday bounties so that you can
level up your new exotic faster this way
you can capitalize on thursday and
friday's bounties make sure to pick up
the urn of sacrifice quest from eris
morn you purchase the urn from zur the
cost is unknown as of now but the rumor
is that this will give you the husk of
pit which should give you the first
iteration of the new exotic auto-rifle
necro chasm if you happen to be low on
strange coins make sure to do your
weeklies so that you'll have the
straight points to buy either exotic
shards or any of the new items of zero
selling good luck Guardians let us hope
sir doesn't sell some breakers or void
bank vestment upgrade
but he probably will
you